Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Sonia Escudero Sánchez
Etanol: esta molécula, constituida
por unos pocos átomos de carbono,
es la responsable de la embriaguez.
A menudo denominado simplemente alcohol,
el etanol es el ingrediente activo
de las bebidas alcohólicas.
Su simpleza lo ayuda
a escabullirse en las membranas
y anidar en muchos rincones diferentes,
produciendo más efectos
que otras moléculas menos sofisticadas.
¿Cómo se causa la embriaguez exactamente
y por qué produce efectos
tan diferentes en personas distintas?
Para contestar estas preguntas
tendremos que seguir al alcohol
en su recorrido por el organismo.
El alcohol llega hasta el estómago
y allí es absorbido por la sangre
a través del tubo digestivo,
especialmente el intestino delgado.
El contenido del estómago
afecta la capacidad del alcohol
de entrar en la sangre porque,
después de comer, el esfínter pilórico,
que separa el estómago
del intestino delgado, se cierra.
Así que el nivel de alcohol
que ingresa a la sangre después de comer
será apenas un cuarto de
lo que ingresaría con el estómago vacío.
De la sangre, el alcohol
se traslada a los órganos,
especialmente a aquellos
que reciben mayor flujo sanguíneo:
el hígado y el cerebro.
Llega primero al hígado,
y las enzimas de este órgano descomponen
la molécula del alcohol en dos pasos.
Primero, una enzima llamada ADH
transforma el alcohol
en acetaldehído, que es tóxico.
Luego, una enzima llamada ALDH
convierte el acetaldehído tóxico
en acetato no tóxico.
A medida que la sangre circula, el hígado
elimina continuamente el alcohol,
pero esta primera eliminación
determina cuánto alcohol
llega al cerebro y a otros órganos.
La sensibilidad del cerebro
es responsable de los efectos emocionales,
cognitivos y de comportamiento
del alcohol,
que se conocen como embriaguez.
El alcohol activa el principal freno
del cerebro, el neurotransmisor GABA,
y desactiva su principal gas,
el neurotransmisor glutamato.
Esto hace a las neuronas
mucho menos comunicativas
y, en dosis moderadas,
las personas se sienten relajadas;
con dosis más altas, se duermen;
y en dosis tóxicas
puede interrumpir la actividad cerebral
necesaria para sobrevivir.
El alcohol también estimula
a un pequeño grupo de neuronas
que se extienden del mesencéfalo
al núcleo accumbens,
una región importante para la motivación.
Como todas las drogas adictivas,
produce un aumento de dopamina
en el núcleo accumbens,
lo que causa en las personas
una sensación de placer.
El alcohol también hace que
algunas neuronas se sinteticen
y liberen endorfinas.
Las endorfinas nos ayudan a calmarnos
en momentos de estrés o peligro.
Los niveles altos de endorfina
contribuyen a la euforia y a la relajación
que se asocia con el consumo de alcohol.
Finalmente, a medida que la descomposición
del alcohol en el hígado
es mayor que su absorción
en el cerebro, la embriaguez pasa.
Las diferencias individuales
en cualquier punto de este recorrido
pueden ocasionar que las personas
actúen más o menos ebrias.
P. ej., un hombre y una mujer que
pesan lo mismo y beben la misma cantidad
durante una cena idéntica
tendrán diferentes concentraciones
de alcohol en sangre, o BAC.
Esto se debe a que
las mujeres tienen menos sangre;
en promedio, tienen
mayor porcentaje de grasa,
lo que requiere menos sangre que músculo.
Un volumen menor de sangre por la cual
circula la misma cantidad de alcohol
significa que la concentración
será más alta en las mujeres.
Las diferencias genéticas en las enzimas
del hígado que procesan el alcohol
también influyen en la concentración.
Beber con regularidad puede aumentar
la producción de estas enzimas,
lo cual ocasiona tolerancia.
Por otro lado, quienes beben
en exceso por mucho tiempo
pueden desarrollar daño hepático,
que tiene el efecto opuesto.
Por su parte, las diferencias
genéticas en la transmisión
de dopamina, GABA y endorfinas
puede aumentar el riesgo de desarrollar
trastorno por consumo de alcohol.
Quienes naturalmente tienen niveles bajos
de dopamina y endorfinas
suelen automedicarse con la bebida.
Hay quienes tienen mayores
probabilidades de beber en exceso
debido a una mayor
actividad de las endorfinas
que aumenta los efectos
placenteros del alcohol.
Otros presentan una variación
en la transmisión GABA
que los vuelve especialmente sensibles
al efecto sedante del alcohol,
lo que disminuye el riesgo
de desarrollar alcoholismo.
El cerebro se adapta
al consumo crónico de alcohol
reduciendo la transmisión
de GABA, dopamina y endorfinas
y aumentando la producción de glutamato.
Esto quiere decir
que los bebedores asiduos
suelen tener ansiedad, dificultades
para dormir y experimentan menos placer.
Estos cambios estructurales y funcionales
pueden producir un consumo excesivo,
cuando beber se siente como algo normal
y no beber se siente incómodo.
Se establece así un círculo vicioso.
Así que tanto la genética
como las experiencias previas
afectan la forma en que
se experimenta el alcohol:
algunas personas son más propensas
a ciertos hábitos de consumo que otras,
y un historial de consumo conlleva
cambios neuronales y de comportamiento.